en medio de refugios improvisados en la
frontera entre Sudán y chat esta mujer
tuvo que huir de su país cuando unos
hombres armados llamaron a su puerta a
duras penas consiguió llegar a este
campo de refugiados pero sin su familia
bajo amenazas salimos a toda prisa en
burro para venir aquí me separé de mis
siete hijos y no los encuentro hemos
visto a nuestros padres masacrados por
las milicias a pesar de no haber hecho
nada somos Víctimas de una barbarie
gratuita no lo entiendo
y cuando no pueden huir hacia el oeste
eligen el norte hacia Egipto estos
autobuses condujeron toda la noche desde
por Sudán en la costa Oriental del mar
Rojo tardaron casi 15 horas en llegar a
este punto fronterizo con el recuerdo de
los combates aún vivo en sus mentes
despiertas todos los días con el sonido
de los disparos
estaba en casa y me entraron cuatro
balas
gracias a Dios estoy bien lo más
importante es que Hemos llegado a Egipto
estos civiles están ahora a salvo la ONU
espera un Éxodo masivo de cientos de
miles de refugiados en los próximos días